the primary goals of the sensory systems
really are three one is to find food
yeah is to avoid danger or avoid being
food
and the third is to seek mates and all
of the three are essential of course for
the survival of individuals and the
species
sensory systems allow animals to take in
information from the world
for their benefit
for example for a single cell bacterium
it needs to find food
and it uses receptor on its cell surface
to detect nutrient molecules the five
common senses are sight of vision
smell or affection
taste or gas station hearing or audition
and the somatosensation which is such
temperature and some chemical senses
they are all carried out isometosensory
systems so photon is what is detected by
the visual system and then the olfactory
and The Taste systems are so-called
chemical senses that they detect
chemicals in different ranges
olfaction actually has a pretty variable
range could be far away could be in the
back of your mouth and a taste usually
is a very close range because the food
has to be in your mouth hearing is most
is purely detecting mechanical stimuli
the vibration
that happens in your inner ear and the
somatosensory system is interesting it's
a multi-modal systems it has different
kind of sensory neurons some of which
are detecting touch or pressure which is
a mechanical stimuli other are detecting
chemicals like itchy substance or the
Hot Chili Pepper peppercorns that go
through your mouth
and others are detecting temperature
changes
and these are five senses referred to
external sensory systems we also have
internal sensory systems or
interoception so interception is the
sensation of your own body and organs
and how they function it's for instance
how full your bladder is or your stomach
is or your lung is inflated so that it
will tell you you know whether you need
to go to bathroom you need to eat or you
should stop eating or you should inhale
more oxygen
so they of course they are all essential
for the survival of the animal so
interroception is no less important that
external reception
for many animals they actually have the
so-called extraordinary senses one
example is the Magneto reception they
are used by migrating birds and
butterflies to carry out their long
distance migrations there is also
Electro Exception by some of the fish
that detect electrical fields
studying sensory systems actually have a
lot of experimental advantages that
allow researchers to identify general
principles of how nervous systems work
by using sensory system as a model one
example is that action potential the
signal between neurons to neurons they
either have it or they don't have it the
all non-properties of the action
potential was discovered originally by
studying
somatosensory system
or sensory systems share some calming
features
they express specific receptors to
detect a specific sensory stimuli
it will convert sensory stimuli into
electric signals a Common Language
understood by the rest of the nervous
system
they optimize detection sensitivity
reliability and a speed and they extract
useful biological information for the
benefit of the animal
foreign